[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round six of the
summer classic here in st. Louis in
Group A samsa beyond even his lifetime
score against Jeffrey Zhang with a win
as white the victory keeps heavy on in
contention with a COPI on and Dhirubhai
Lea ahead of him in Group B Camille
dragon continued his winning ways
against a lemur on D the pole had a
powerful pawn clump that was set to win
a piece even with three other wins in
the group if dragon doesn't stumble he
should win the event coverage of round
seven starts now twenty international
chess professionals compete in st. Louis
as us chess champs calm presents the
first ever summer chess classic
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the st. Louis
chess club studio and the 2018 Summer
chess classic I am women Grandmaster
katrien EMTALA and I'm here with
international master Eric Rosen today we
have round seven of the summer chess
classic tournament the tournament is
slowly but surely approaching the end
it's true only three rounds to go
including this one and there's leaders
in both groups but still many players
fighting for the top spots so let's see
what are the yesterday's results for a
group a yeah we had Benjamin brought
back drawing received our Bailey Peter /
Houska drawing version Cobian - decisive
games in the field euros Arabic
defeating Renato mabye of and Sam
Sevilla and defeating Jeffrey Zhang in
really creative opening preparation and
then of course Daniel Friedman drawing
Alexander in Jets if we take a look at
the standings we can see this Easter
Bailey is still in clear first with a
very impressive 5 out of 6 points and
then revision Akopian right behind with
four and a half points and 7 Sam Savion
right behind him with 4 points and the
results for the group EP we had only one
undecisive results were circling
Motsinger drew again against Andres to
copying otherwise all games were
decisive Daenerys adieu a cassava one
against Alejandro Ramirez camel dragon
the leader of the tournament B 1 against
JJ ally Miranda Tata
Abraham Ian one against Vladimir Bellas
and Josh Fredette lost to Robert a
Kazarian this brings us to standings and
we still see at camel dragon is the sole
leader with four and half points out of
six and we have a tie for the second
spot where Sergei Machiko and race took
open and Robert agus re on all have
three and health points out of six and
if Camille can keep his cool just in the
final rounds I mean a full point lead
over the rest of the field should give
him good chances to capture the first
place and a tournament format we have to
tell play around Roberts with the time
control 90 minutes 440 moves plus 30
minutes for the remainder of their game
with a thirty second increment from
one and we should keep in mind there's a
30 move no draw rule so players can not
agree to a draw before move 30 which has
led some to some very exciting chests so
far and a schedule yeah we have games
starting at 1:00 p.m. for next two days
the final day Wednesday the 23rd games
start at 11:00 a.m. and if there's a tie
in any section which is very possible
the playoff will be at 5:00 p.m. on
Wednesday the 23rd so let's see the
pairings for today for group a we have
Alexander engage playing Benjamin Bach
Jeffrey Zhang playing Daniel Friedman
Rena Juma by F against Sam savvy and
Verico bein against the Irish Arabic and
the leader of acid or Baily against his
teammate Peter Prohaska the key matchup
of today version of Cobian against euros
Arabic version in clear second place
trying to get some momentum going into
the final rounds if we take a look at
the current position we can see both
players intently focused there at the
board the position seems a bit favorable
for var given just given the palm
structure he has a very beautiful
defendant passed pawn on d5 also very
nice Bishop and queen battery directed
at the Kings side so I feel like far
maybe can grind this out for for the
next many moves and this is not the only
time we see this bone structure I think
we headed in couple rounds before were
the strong d5 pawn supported by c4 was
bringing some advantage to the players
yeah if I'm not mistaken far had the
very similar bone structure against
Geoffrey Jean which he he ground down
the endgame very nicely to take the
point home and I know these positions
suit var style very well he likes having
small advantages that he can play on and
on and on and just try and provoke
mistakes from his opponent yeah and it's
important to it's interesting to know
that vara cobia and a yo-yo buddha are
both very strong american grandmasters
both played each other in the u.s.
championship I believe in 2017 and both
live in st. Louis well it's true it's
gonna be an exciting fight but let's go
on and take a look at the matchups for
Group B we do have some exciting games
underway Robert Iger sorry and against
Daenerys to do it the Silva Vladimir
ballast against Josh Reed l JJ Allen
Morandi against Tata of agronomy and
Andres do copan already drawing his
teammate camille dragon and a very quick
game and Alejandra Ramirez against sir
game at Cinco and a key matchup for
growl for group B was andreas to copying
against the leader cameo dragon the
match is over already the coach
teammates decided to make a draw let's
take a look at the game yeah I don't
want to spend too much time on this game
it was a very complex theoretical battle
in the night ourf but I actually looked
up the theory before the broadcast and
on move 25 after a night take f7 this
exact position has occurred in a good
handful of masters games I'm sure both
players were prepared through this
moment and probably because they were
teammates they didn't want to go into
maybe unknown territory and they just
stayed with with their opening
preparation and kummel had a very
important when if I'm not mistaken
yesterday so he has just two rounds to
go he's the sole leader he had black now
I mean draw is a good result for him
that's very true and we should see what
the players are fighting for there's
lots of money on the line 22,000 dollars
up for grabs in Group A with $6,000 for
first place and the price fund is also
very generous for Group B the total
prize fund is $14,000 and the winner
takes $4,000 home and especially towards
the later rounds I mean every half point
counts and we'll see if anyone in Group
B can catch up to tournament leader
kamil dragon so let's stay with the
group B tournament and let's look at the
game
JJ Ali morandi against at a fabrica me
and JJ sacrificed an exchange there very
interesting game so what's happening
there yeah we can see JJ just got off
from the bora tata pondering her next
move i do want to go back and look at
the opening because JJ did something
very peculiar in a symmetrical english
variation going forward here it seems
like this is very well known territory
I played the sign myself as whites but
going forward right around here JJ
played this very bold move c4 extending
the pawn further perhaps discouraging
white from advancing the B or D pawns b3
was played and then after Bishop f5 JJ
played a move which came to a complete
shock to me
he just completely ignored the rook on
v1 captured on c4 and went down the
exchange if you ever seen something like
this before I look at the position and I
see that Grand Master Turkey's real
master JT la Miranda thought on move
nine rugby one for five minutes next
move for three minutes I would expect
something like this if you have a home
preparation and you know what's
happening but if you thought about this
on board I mean that's a very
interesting idea and no I I think it's
always very risky to sacrifice an
exchange so early not knowing what's
happening what's happening later yeah we
should note that I mean white does have
one point for the exchange more center
pawns and sometimes in the middle game
minor pieces can be more effective than
rooks especially when there's not any
complete open files on the board let's
see how they game continued because it
did seem maybe a bit more pleasant for
white having more central control it's
very feisty move b5 was played trying to
perhaps open some lines for the rooks
later on so you take b5 and I take b5
and then a very wild tactical move
Knight g5 not only threatening this mate
on h7 but also unleashing the bishop
going after the 9 @ c6 so it seems like
something was calculated by the white
side I think this is very important you
know that the bishop on g2 I mean the
light squares are so weak in the black
camp and finally what is ready to take
control of them and now we can think
whether the bishop is better than the
rook or not that's true going forward in
the game after F take g5 Bishop takes c6
white is still down the exchange but has
initiative also has completely destroyed
black's pawn structure this pawn on e5
very weak just being eyed by the bishop
on b2 and we can really see that the
power of the two bishops in such an open
position and also we see that Tata has
less than 10 minutes and she needs to
makes 15 move before 15 moves before she
gets another 30 minutes for the rest of
the game let's actually zoom forward to
the current position because it appears
that JJ has won back the exchange after
a 497 Bishop a3 just a simple tactic I
wonder if this is perhaps missed by Tata
a
for being a very nice move clearing the
a3 square for the bishop and given
blacks Queen and rook are aligned on
this diagonal does not it's not bode
well for Fort octave in this position
and if you fast forward yeah let's get
to the current position bishop take a
eight played winning back the exchange
and Knight c3 roti eight brings us to
the current position actually I see one
more move has been played rook to be one
and I mean it just seems much more
preferable for whites and let's look at
the bishop on f6 I mean that's such a
sad piece it cannot go anywhere only
backward on e7 comfortably the bishop on
c6 there's a many light squares to
control and why this pawn app I think
like it's some disadvantage here yeah
extra pawn batter structure better
better pieces much more harmony among
the white pieces and the black pieces
very impressed with with JJ's opening
preparation and his very enthusiastic
middle gameplay and if we look at the
time situation to I mean he has just
under forty minutes
Tata below ten minutes I think AJ is or
JJ is the one to be the predicted winner
in this game so let's go back to the
tournament a we have some results there
Geoffrey's young drew against Danielle
Freedman and Alexandra indeed drew
against Benjamin Spock wow you can see
the the empty boards there may be some
some players just wanting to conserve
energy towards the later rounds of the
tournament I'm looking at the final
position between Alexander and itch and
Benjamin Bach it just wants me or really
puts me to sleep just looking at the
board officer Clark bishops symmetrical
structure and nothing to play for free
either side so let's see what's the
board of Geoffrey's young against Daniel
Friedman yeah maybe a bit more life in
this position I'm curious what prompted
them to agree to a draw looks like move
twenty nine rook T two is played so they
agreed to a draw right before the the
move thirty going back to see how that
happened H three Queen C five rook T 2
so they repeated after Queen c1 rook d1
Queen C five white saw nothing better
than just to play rough do you two and
goes for the same variation
I mean when we see this position the
black is controlling the c-file the
night is very active on e5 it's very
hard to find something good for white
here I mean that's true yeah and maybe
Geoffrey wanted just to regroup from
yesterday given he had a very tough loss
against an Savion sometimes a quick draw
in the next round isn't such a bad
result just blow off some steam and save
as much energy as possible for the last
couple of rounds so I suggest to look
now at the game
Renate mabye up against Sam Sevilla yeah
this is definitely heating up we have a
position with all major pieces and I'm
not sure who should be the one attacking
I mean it it's very clear white has
initiative here after rook d7 hitting
the Queen on e7 but we should note that
White's King is a bit exposed on f2 and
white doesn't have the the better pawn
structure so is there a side that you
would prefer in this position I
explained it there were we there will be
some Queen trades and Al Jarreau can
game and rook and games as we know they
are very often draws but black has some
issues to solve I mean the rook on the
seventh rank is active it is attacking
the pawn on a7 so black has to move
somewhere the Queen probably six or
eight yeah we should know it like the
Queen on e7 is almost trapped I mean
there's not too many squares Queen e6
Queen e8 being to Canada that moves
maybe Queen f6 is also a can be a
consideration but it seems like white
might be winning a pawn we should keep
in mind that pawn in a7 is hanging and
black isn't getting much activity
against the King on f2 black can also
choose to just capture a queen on a5 but
let's see the position if rook takes a5
rook takes Queen rook takes rook now we
see that a pawn on a 7 is still attacked
and moves like rook e8 I mean that looks
horrible that is so passive that is so
dangerous for black so what is keeping
some advantage here I've actually taught
very similar games my students this is a
very instructive rook endgame situation
where it's equal material but the big
difference is white has active
and black has a passive rook and
sometimes that difference alone can make
the game decisive given that black's
rook is just stuck on the back rank and
white can very easily keep improving
with advancing the pawns getting the
King to a better position and later on
this could win - this could lead to
winning material and maybe creating a
passed pawn so I would have to put my
money on white in this game I mean at
first I thought it's kind of draw age
and there will be some exchanges but now
I'm changing my mind I think black is
actually in trouble yeah and we can see
Sam they're not appearing to be too
comfortable kind of fidgeting around I
mentioned this a few days ago but when
you see your opponent fidgeting it's
usually a good sign that they're they're
not too happy with the situation so I'm
sure Sam is considering his options here
trying to figure out the best way to try
and equalize the position the good part
for Sam is he still has 17 minutes which
is a lot of time for Grandmaster to
think about the lines calculated and
evaluate what is the best position that
can hold the draw so let's move on to a
different game what about the Baraka
beyond against CRL jariabek we had some
trades there I believe yes some
developments in this game this is our
matchup of today for Group A and when we
last left Queens were still on the board
we should go back to see where the
Queen's got traded Bishop f4 was played
and bishops got traded on f4 and then
rookie 4 just seems like a lot of a lot
of trading down rough taking for Queen
take e for lots of trades on e4 after
rook e8 92 this brings us to the current
position where maybe whites for choice
but because so many trades took place it
seems like Black has some drawing
chances in this position I agree White
has a very nice idea of maybe pushing a5
at some moment to try to break through
there weaken some pawns and I mean open
the B file so the rook can attack there
the pawns I do like this idea a5 is is
definitely a very big positional thread
in the position because I mean b6 is a
very clear target and black would never
be happy with a line like a 5 B take a 5
given the rook could could infiltrate
and start winning pawns
so yeah maybe Ivar has something to play
for here we should also keep in mind it
is a situation bishops of the same color
and for the time being White's pawns are
fixed on light squares so maybe that
gives some edge to black but we should
know that this Bishop on h5 completely
out of place so maybe maybe not not much
black can argue in this position so
maybe black would like to play something
like 97 and Bishop g6
but a problem is that I can make teams
at once and if I go 97 right now maybe
Bishop Bishop f5 can be coming and again
I'm just forcing the knight to go away
and then I'm able to play a 5 mm-hmm
yeah because 997 I mean it's it's one of
the few pieces that can defend the b6
square I would be curious if maybe black
can get some activity for the night
maybe 95 but I assume you would just go
ahead and play a vibe in this position
mm-hmm yeah a 5 is certainly unpleasant
to deal with this was not played black
black shows the very direct Bishop g6
perhaps just going for the tray the
bishops because of the more trades maybe
they eat the easier it is to hold on in
the position and I do like to smooth
because now black is actually preparing
97 and not allowing this very pesky
Bishop to f5 so what can either play
move like a free but most likely most
likely we are gonna take and maybe play
King F 1 to defend an e 2 square from
the rook coming there yeah so line like
Bishop take g6 8086 King F 1 I think
black by maybe is still slightly worse
given the the very nice pawn on d5 but I
I wouldn't think it's enough for for
white to actually win this position
mm-hmm so we did not take a look at the
leader of this tournament Vasi do reveal
a let's let's see what's happening in
the game passive Dhirubhai like against
Peter Prohaska yeah and that's a very
key matchup for the standings given the
Seif is a leader in Group A he's playing
his Webster teammate Peter Piroska so
I'm sure the the two players know each
other very well if we look at the
position a lot has been traded
we have a situation with two bishops and
a knight for each side the Seif just
playing this this pawn in Venice pawn g5
and I mean really the the position seems
relatively balanced maybe I would have
to slightly prefer black given there's a
bit more harmony a bit more central
control with the minor pieces white
seems to be a bit passive but I really
don't see any weaknesses that white has
to worry about I feel like today is a
very peaceful round there are a lot of
trades a lot of end games
everything looks somewhat equal maybe
the players are getting a little tired
it's possible I mean everyone's human
and chest can take a toll on physical
energy so sometimes this is what happens
towards the later stages of the
tournament but one game which certainly
was not peaceful and still isn't
peaceful is a fight between vladimir
bellows and josh free del if we take a
look at the current position whites just
up the exchange it should just be a
routine win for whites and we should
note that flat flat marabella's not
having the best tournament
I believe he only has half a point out
of 6 but if he can win today at least
it's some some reconciliation going into
the final rounds compared to a Josh
Fidel had a very solid tournament all
draws then round 5 he won but the
yesterday he had his first loss so it's
a we talked about it yesterday how it's
very difficult to kind of get back to
determined after after a tough lost lost
so it may be not easy for him to now
play again with black and having a
difficult position yeah it's the concept
of momentum - sometimes if you lose a
game you just get in this a negative
mindset and it's really important to
stay disciplined and really try your
best in every game because you don't
want to be losing game after game and
not being able to fight back but I am
curious how glad Amir actually won the
exchange we were taking a look at the
game earlier and it seemed like Vladimir
was playing some very creative ideas
going for the King side attack let's go
for it
or let's go back to this position after
Bishop f4 and see how the game actually
develops because at some point we saw
this very very spectacular move rook g6
hitting the Queen on f6
and we should note that rook can't be
taken due to the this classic pawn take
g6 and and simple mating idea queen h7
mates so I do like the creativity and
lights attack from this position let's
go forward and see what happened Queen
e7 played trade happened on d6
and it's pretty funny that White's rook
can just die on g6 because it can't be
taken I like this move Knight f4 trying
to bring another piece into the attack
and I was actually joking earlier it
would be nice and for white in this
position to be able to capture his own
rook because that would result in
winning the Queen of course that that's
not that's not possible here if I don't
really play a maybe the very slow but
prophylactic moved pawn a3 preventing
any counter play from black with Queen
before let's go forward here because I'm
still curious how White's
ended up winning material rook g2 played
Wow 96 a simple simple fork and I
believe black did not want to take the
knight on g6 given this was very scary
mating idea with with queen h7 if I'm
not mistaken I don't think Bach has any
way to escape to mate here I mean black
and try Knight f6 but then rogue h2 is
coming and now there is a checkmate on
h8 yeah this is this is a very classic
meeting I like to show a lot of younger
kids because it's such a common pattern
in chess where you have a pawn on g6
against a castle King and you also have
control over the open H file and bad
things happen to black in this position
yes I want to go back a little bit
before the rook retreated to G - I'm
very often asked by younger players like
I'm attacking what should i do how can I
really you know win the game and I'm
always saying like think about your
pieces make sure they are in their best
pot so in this position the rook is not
doing anything anymore on g6 so that's
why radomir decides to retreat and
actually improve the night so I think
this is a very nice idea to kind of
understand how to move around with your
pieces even though maybe Daru cannot be
captured on g6 it does not attack there
but the knight is way more powerful
there so sometimes maybe you want to
flip around with your
to to make the most efficient attack
yeah it's it's not an easy move to fund
because when you're attacking you you
usually think for think about forward
moves not backward moves but in this
case because the rook was occupying the
square that the knight wanted to get to
rook to you to May that made a lot of
sense in the position and we can see in
aichi six just one material four White's
going forward white took on f8 and I'm
counting pawns here black does not have
a single pawn for the exchange so I
think Josh is just trying to pray for a
miracle here but it's it's not going to
help and after a white sauce move rook
g6 we can see white should cruise to
victory pretty soon I mean it looks
white has an easy plan just go back go
forward with the key and maybe King dick
to move the rook around
yeah I think white has a big advantage
and very unfortunate position for black
so let's move on here another game that
catches my eye in Group B is a battle
between Robert Auguste Arion and
Daenerys Sidhu cassava we were looking
at the position earlier we were fading
favoring white from the positional stand
points given that blacks bishop is so
bad on f7 but we have we do have to
admire the amazing control that Black
has over the only open file on the board
which side would you take in this
position so you're a squid side well I
see the bishop on f7 and I really don't
like it again it's just staring at its
own pawns it doesn't have anywhere where
to go
on the other end like does have the C
file so we have to kind of think what's
what's good and what's bad but I do feel
that I would prefer white because
there's also weakness on b7
I feel like white pieces are more having
cooperation and just having a better
squares here I mean if you pick white I
would have to pick back in this position
black does have the initiative
especially with the last move pawn 85
kicking the Queen away from b4 and I
guess it is a question of whether black
can keep the initiative or if white can
somehow stabilize and steer the game
into more positional waters but one
thing that really catches my eye in this
position is this weakness for white on
e3 and even though it's not being
attacked
only if black can somehow shuffle the
the pieces over perhaps
reposition the rook get the rook to e8
perhaps play the very simple works III
and it's not so easy for white to defend
the pawn and I think it's very easy for
that to get all the major pieces
attacking this this target on e3 so we
will see whether Black has an advantage
here or white but we do have a result in
round round 7 intrument be where Ali GJ
our lemur and a one against Tata Abraham
Ian so he sacrificed the exchange and he
proved to to have compensation for it
very impressive play by JJ hopefully we
can get him in the studio he has not
been interviewed so far this event but
this game has to be one of his better
games in the tournament we have to know
that he lost yesterday he had a tough
situation but he was able to to get back
and I mean he had a very nice game yeah
let's see how the game ended because it
seemed like I mean he had a very clear
advantage up upon and maybe tot often
pull up the best fights coming forward
from this position let's go for it rook
b1 King h8 I mean White's pieces are
just crawling all over a black in this
position Queen d6 played between c4 a 6
and White's pieces get keep getting
better and better and better
94 hitting the Queen on g6 hitting the
bishop on f6 after Queen e7 night I got
6g take f6 Bishop before talked of
resigned here I didn't want to fight on
anymore I mean we seen a total dominance
of the under light squares the bishop is
amazing the knight doesn't have where to
go and we also have to keep in mind that
white is still upon up this is a this is
a lost position for black yeah so any
other games to take a look at any games
catch your eye Katarina no okay well
let's see let's see what we have here
maybe we can go back and take a look at
the fight between Sam Sevilla and
Renacci mabye of let's go back to where
we last left off few moves ago
black played queen eh keeping Queens on
the board but look at this awkward
Sabbath Queen on I ate raw con f fate
not what Locke wants to go for in this
position let's go forward Queen d3 rook
a5 a3 and h6 brings us to the current
position I mean I have to pick white
here it seems like pieces are very well
coordinated we're actually going to take
a break and be back with an interview
hopefully we can get JJ here sorry a
moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get 24
by 7 coverage of chest news and events
access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get advised from the best
and even challenge them to a battle be
the best chess player you can be it's
time to level up your game with just 24
premium membership
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
all right
back everyone I'm international master
Eric Rosen joined by Grandmaster JJ a
lemur Andy congratulations after a very
nice win over taught to robert abraham
ian yeah thank you
it was an interesting game and okay yeah
let's take us through it I do want to
ask about the opening given that you
played this very peculiar exchange
sacrificed so early wanted to ask if
that was opening preparation or really
actually if we can take it for like even
like from the move one actually uh-huh
she normally plays an Enzo Indian and I
thought that if I go see four she will
probably respond with Yi six and I
thought I can try to go with lines with
antonyms or like Knight c3 and tried to
go for an early attack of g4 if she goes
Bishop before so I I had this just to
show that on the board I'm an info
player myself and it should be g-forces
I was in the mood of playing very
aggressive chess and of course I didn't
analyze it in great depth but I actually
wanted to play something like this
because there are not many games and
it's definitely good to try something
new I'm not a knight of 3c four-player
therefore she actually responded with c5
which came as a surprise and I'm kind of
out of book mm-hmm because I played this
move order generally when my opponents
don't play c5 I mean obviously I've
checked it before but not specifically
for this game because I thought she
wouldn't go for c5 but based on like
previous memories I just played a few
moves and seemed like a somewhat
standards right 97 and probably a3 is
more precise after 97 mm-hmm I'm not
100% sure but because I'm not really a
English player so I'm not fair enough
sometimes you have to improvise in
situations like this right so I just
went 8 3 rugby 8 her idea is basically
if I go B 4 instead of rook b1 she just
wants to take with the pawn takes Bishop
takes 95 that's like the main idea takes
a fortnight's he's
and if I go Bishop c6 the rook protects
the bishop so that's the whole idea of
rook b8 and that kind of caught me so
you can't go for that standard plan yeah
so I just played so let's go forward
here because you thought to have played
a very ambitious move on c4 because I I
think this made me think that I actually
miss played the whole opening because
now I cannot really go t3 mm-hmm and she
just wants to probably develop Bishop a5
someday or maybe just finished
development with Bishop e7 and castles
so I played b3 I thought this would kind
of help me develop quickly if c b3 Queen
takes and I have ideas like Knight g5
because the rook on b8 is pinned like
Bishop takes c6 but obviously her
intention was Bishop a5 which I kind of
missed but luckily I just took on c4
which is interesting I believe because
there's like she took on b1 obviously
and I took I mean all my pieces are
almost in the back rank it's funny that
if she goes like e 4 I have to go like
91 or something so Wow
down material and down material and
passive but like I thought it's not that
bad the engines might be like laughing
at White's play but I thought it's
practical at least after it takes she
obviously didn't go for you for Bishop
e7 Bishop b2 made sense I thought kind
like Bishop f6 was the more logical move
for some reason because after f6 I
thought that this a a 2 g8 diagonal kind
of gets weaker and I have ideas like
Knight h4 Knight of 5 so it did seem
more fun to play for whites right after
f6 especially I kind of felt happier
because I see Queen c2 my idea is
basically I'm either gonna go III d4 I'm
basically stopping Queen d3 mm-hmm and
if she castles my main intention was
just to go Knight age for Bishop e4 and
just tried to pile up on 87 and the King
because it's not a bad idea given that
you're the only player with the lights
for Bishop right exactly
and if she if I managed to provoke
eight-six the light squares would
actually be completely under my control
oh this would be this would be great
actually because I also have a pawn for
that compensation it's not that mm-hmm
I'm not like down on material and now I
do have to ask as a situation like this
in bughouse is very bad for black
inspired by some blog house concept and
concepts I mean in bughouse especially
you can like second exchange and it
doesn't really matter because the minor
pieces are the general true travel some
from the partners board so I felt like
playing something aggressive and since
we're almost playing it buckeyes
everyday at the chess house so I was
like let's just try to play something
interesting after unfortunate loss
yesterday so Queen d7 III castles and my
main intention was to go d4 instead of
rook t1 but I figured that she takes
takes and she goes b5 and I just
couldn't refute this and if she manages
to block it on d5 I'm not sure what I'm
doing correct
so I played rugby 1 which i think is
actually inaccurate I think Roxy one is
much better because her idea is b5
clearly and I have to find a way to stop
it b5 doesn't work now because I take
real taste attack in the night the
problem is I can't take on c6 yet but I
can go nice g5 and after fg5 Bishop c6
and now I attack two pieces at the same
time that's a nice and Queen f5 never
attacks f2 because I just take the Queen
so this is a good line and therefore I
would be stopping b5 and I would prepare
the 4 with an easier push but I played
rook e1 and she immediately played b5
which is correct I think and the
position was getting very crazy I mean
we were having yet time figuring out
what's going on here
see b5 and maybe rook b5 is more
accurate with the idea that if I go with
Knight g5 f jf f G Bishop c6 now he has
rook takes b2 and if Queens you for
Queen e6 so I cannot do this fancy line
Andrew consi one was great because the
Queen was actually protected at the
moment oh that's true but here I can go
like Knight c3 and try to play on but I
feel like Black has solved the problems
actually mhm
she took with the Knights which kind of
gives me more chances because now I have
Knight g5 very nice and I'm very nice
resource in the position it definitely
is good but I don't think it's like
better for white or anything maybe she
takes takes I'm not sure Queen e6 is
probably the right move Queen d6 was not
expected from my side I was just
expecting Queen e6 maybe I just missed
something but Queen b6 the idea is if I
give a check on either b3 or c4 and take
the knight she's gonna go a6 and my
bishop won't be to his pins forever so I
played Queen e4 with just the mini trick
that if she goes Bishop f6 which she did
and there's a fourth so she's just
overlooked a four here the problem which
took me so long to play Queenie for like
a few minutes was Queen f6 because
attacking f2 and also preparing moves
like Knight d6 and so on so I can go
like f3 but there's 96 Queen d5 maybe
but like Knight f7 and you just hold
everything so I was not very sure what's
going on in this position but I was
going to calculate definitely more I see
after seeing Bishop f6 the rest was
quite easy I have to say because I won
the exchange so it just seemed like a
tactical oversight from Tata and
sometimes this is what happens percent
of the tournament players just got tired
and sometimes of it was that was because
the bishop was never taking the real
gonna fate but now suddenly it's just
attacking and have to like the critical
line I was worried not worried but like
was definitely calculating is 94 mm-hmm
because the bishop is both bishops are
attacked I have to go Bishop g5 check I
thought King h8 Bishop e3 now I checked
92 but I can either go to g2 or f1 King
f1 is also nice Queen a6 Bishop c4 Queen
takes a 4
and King take situ and I'm safe sounds
like you have everything under control
and III because I just wanted to trade
the district that's off exactly so this
was a nice line obviously not forced but
it's an interesting one to check check
and after 97 I don't think like as any
counterplay because I played Bishop III
26 takes takes Knight c3 just seemed
like a very healthy position for like
just a matter wait and Ruby won I mean
if she wants to play on I think she just
has to take on d2 because she taught for
like five six minutes it's probably lost
anyways but try to get the pawn back
after rook b7 maybe something like
Bishop d8 or something like this because
it's very ugly I have to say to play
with black here but what to do I
definitely a very early physician after
okay seven it's probably dead no well
congratulations nice nice victory today
do you know who do you know who you play
tomorrow yeah I'll actually be playing
my roommate Josh Friedel Josh Goodell
who you're rooming with this tournament
I assume so is this someone you played
before do you have any thoughts going
into the game I haven't ever played them
but we're like good friends at the
moment so we'll see how that goes
okay and I do want to bring up one more
thing before you go I know you've
started streaming on Twitch very
recently can you tell us a bit about
that and how viewers can watch you play
play live with commentary yeah I started
doing twitch and as well as a YouTube
channel on the side and I've been doing
this around like two two and a half
months and I play a lot of plates or
solve tactics play bughouse entertaining
stuff my channel name is JJ chess 2018
so they can definitely find it from
there I like it it's quite fun and just
want to like entertain people with and
maybe a new chest style a little more
energetic aggressive and practical so
that's the goal I think if I can
entertain people I'll be glad that's
great well I won't keep you any longer
best of luck in your in the rest of your
games and we're gonna take a quick break
and we'll be back with more coverage of
the 28th
summer chess classic this August the
best chess players in the world are
coming to st. Louis with a grand chest
tour st. Louis rapid and blitz and
Sinquefield Cup tournaments will feature
the world's best right here in st. Louis
st. Louis chess club is celebrating its
10th anniversary and these tournaments
will be a highlight you won't want to
miss for tickets and more information go
to st. Louis chess club org
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip in a nearby city you won't be
surprised be intrigued be delighted the
world chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
you
[Music]
you
welcome back everyone to the 2018 summer
chess classic I'm international master
Eric Rosen joined back with Catarina and
Silva welcome back Catarina thank you so
let's go back maybe determined a and see
some of the games there yeah we do we
did have some results in tournament a
but some games still going the fight
between Renacci um abaya and sam Savion
still underway the position is heating
up
queenie 5 just played and seems like
black has perhaps solved the the passive
nature of the Queen and the rook but it
still seems like White has a better
coordination in this position so can we
go back and see how black resolved it
because we thought he's in he's in
trouble yeah going back just a few moves
black played maybe the simple h6 and
perhaps a problem for white in this
position is the pieces are optimized and
it's not actually clear how to make more
progress because everything is defended
in blacks camp so rook c7 was played
maybe going for the Queen trade but
after Queen e5 it's not that easy for
white to force a queen Trey then we do
have to keep in mind White's King is
perhaps a long-term target on f6 so I'm
expecting this to be a pretty long fight
for both sides and the pawn is also very
weak on e 2 so black I saw I mean is the
idea to just get the rooks maybe on the
e-file but we do have to know that the
rook on f4 and rook on c7 are having a
pretty strong attack on this 7 moves
pawn yeah black can't easily activate
the rook on f8
while f7 is still being attacked so it's
it is a question and maybe black just
has to play without the f8 rook in this
position but it's a good point to note
that white does have a number of
weaknesses perhaps more weaknesses in
black given the King on f2 pawn and e2
also the pawn and b2 currently attacked
by the Queen in the position and not to
mention this opponent h2 is well
undefended
maybe black can consider some future
idea like Queen h5 and and trying to
give white some difficulties I'm
thinking one of the choices for a white
here can be maybe Quincy for trying to
even more pressure on f7 pawn I do like
this move Queen c4 does ignore the b2
pawn but it defends the rook and very
importantly attacks probably the biggest
hog in the position pawn and a7 and it
would be a question how does black
actually respond to this because it's
not clear how how black should they find
that 7 another time maybe a move like
Queen Age 5 I think we need 5 it's a
good move because let's see what happens
if Queen takes the pawn on veto which I
feel is a poisonous forest Queen takes
b2 we take the pawn on epsilon with f4
rukia's and now there is a discovered
attack or discover check followed by a
check we don't have 7 so black I think
this is lost no this would not be good
for her doctor going to I think Sam
probably has to play that it's safe in
this position and I mean I would expect
a move like Queen h5 it still seems like
everything is defended white would then
have to defend the pawn in each - maybe
we can expect something like clone h4
and it's it's a complex battle maybe
some chances for both sides given White
has a better piece placement but black
has the the better structure and perhaps
arguably the safer King so let's see
another game Barak will be on the arrows
Arabic it's another fight underway in
Group A every time we look at this game
more things are getting traded looks
like var has finally lost his his past D
pawn on d5 going back a couple moves
yarrow played maybe the simplifying pawn
b5 just going for the pollen exchange
and after C take B 595 I feel like this
game is just heading towards a draw it
looks like that but we do have to know
that after 94 the ninth is having a very
good spot and the pollen b5 is a little
more advanced and the black's pawn that
is true so maybe just a minuscule edge
for curve R in this position we can see
he actually played a different move rook
to c1 perhaps a lot more director just
going after the undefended c5 pawn
putting the question to black how to
defend this pawn me
rook c8 would be forced in this position
and we see that every time black has to
go look CID Lucas very passive and it
frees up our King to to go forward maybe
kingly to King d3 and just go and
blogged upon with a king yeah that's
true
I would I would much prefer far in this
position even though a lot of material
has come off the board he does have a
few Trump's in the position given the
more powerful work on c1 keeping
constant pressure against the c5 pawn
the more centralized king and the
further extended pawn on d5 so perhaps
perhaps far is playing for winning this
game trying to catch up to the leader in
Gervais and rook see it happened in the
game Yara played it and now it's a virus
turn now we do want to know that var has
only 30 seconds left to play seven more
moves before getting extra 30 minutes
after the 40 moves control I didn't even
know this a time situation but that's a
very good point var of course notorious
for getting low on time in this position
15 seconds not a lot of time on the
clock he's gonna have to make a move
played the very quick Knight to c4
gaining the additional 30 seconds and
even though he's better in the position
it's not always easy to play accurate
moves under such a severe time pressure
and my computer says he played Knight e4
oh you aren't right yeah 94 it was
played maybe a more direct attempt going
after the the c5 pawn Yara responded
very quickly with poncey 4 and then far
responded right back with 96 is white
managing to win the c4 pawn in this
position I mean if white gets the pawn
this is gonna be a very very great
position a very comfortable position for
a bar who is extra pawn and can push for
4 more but we see rook d8 happened can I
just take the bone yeah lots of moves
coming at a very rapid pace
you're suggesting just a very simple
Knight takes e4 but then can black
creates some annoying pin perhaps just
rip out to c8 with the simple threat of
Knight b6 and that's very interesting so
you are threatening
be six to put more pressure on the pin
piece so I do have to play rook c2 here
to try to be ready after you play and
I'd be six to be ready to play 93 or 93
still retreating tonight but
defending the rook yeah so move like
rook c2 makes a good amount of sense in
this position given after Knight b6 93
and weight would probably just be up a
clean pawn black has maybe just night
before and with some perpetual I mean
repetitive moves so crook c2 night
before night before it could be quite
annoying you up to c1 and then maybe
Knight d5 back and just repeat the
position that's very true could we try a
different idea for white here maybe just
kinky to try and bring the King into
defended my that's before that's very
nice every time we have an endgame we do
want to bring the King to the center
because the King is no longer under
attack it's it's not in danger so it can
actually help the white pieces to
proceed we can see a move has been
played virtues rook c2 maybe allowing
the repetition but keep in mind you
don't have to accept the threefold
repetition he could repeat once and then
later go for the King e to idea I do
like the strategy given his time
situation it's not always bad to repeat
two times and then deviates given that
it does add some extra time to the clock
so Varney's only three last moves and
then he's gonna get extra 30 minutes to
actually think maybe whether to switch
to the lines and play your idea King e2
and bring the King to the center that's
right well keep an eye on this game but
let's query switched gears very quickly
we do have a results in Group A
tournament leader of a thief Jerry
Bailey had a pretty solid draw against
his teammate Peter pasta in a position
which ended in some sort of obstacle our
Bishop ending going back a few moves
the pieces got traded off very quickly
after b5 seems like everything got
traded off with Justin just within a few
moves that should take before Bishop
takes e4 and this is just a dead draw
I mean white black and try to maybe win
the white pawn on d5 but the king the
white he can always retreat and opposite
colored with shops I mean this is this
is a draw position so should we go back
to the VAR game and just see how they
reach time control a few more moves have
been played after rook C - Yara went for
the very quick Knight to be for rooks
III played and now yaro is is thinking
maybe considering whether to play Knight
e5 back or Knight a - and it is a
question maybe Knight a - could be
better
preventing any sort of rook c1 so after
90 - I may have the only idea of playing
Brooke a3 to actually trading the night
and going for a rook and game not a
question is whether this rook and game
promises anything good but I see that
var already played Roxy - I Roxy - just
repeating the position which means Y ro
played 95 there they might just be
accepting repetition here but as white
being up the pawn I would like to play
for something more but maybe we can see
that rook c1 was not playable in that
position because of 96 right and white
might be losing here so rook rook to c2
probably a forced move and it appears
the players will likely go for the
threefold repetition it is very likely
so I would like to go to term and B we
have some very interesting games we
didn't touch on too much Robert Alcazar
e on against Daenerys adraka Sola what's
happening there let's see oh this
position is heating up when we last left
we were kind of arguing you were
preferring white I was preferring black
we can see the King side has opened up
White's King has found some sort of
shelter on each one I'm not sure how
much shelter it has and black still
appears to have the initiative in this
position maybe we should go back if he
moves see how this position actually
unfolded because Queen b6 was played
rook c1 and then very explosive move f4
coming out of nowhere
not sure what the reasoning is behind
this move maybe - potentially Oh
not some diagonal for the bishop very
strange move it reminds me the game she
had yesterday dinara against Alejandro
Ramirez she also played f-5e five dinar
is a very aggressive player who likes to
have good pieces and good cooperation so
here we see rooks are on C file that's
good but the bishop on f7 is really
blocked it cannot do anything so she
decides to give up this pawn for the
chance of having an active Bishop I I
think it fr is a really strong move yeah
and I think we should also keep in mind
that's aiming to disturb either the III
or the g3 pawn we should note that eta
got four would not be playable due to
Queen takes e4 and the move that was
played in the game GTA got four just
creates some more open line for the King
along this diagonal and I think black
very wisely played the repositioning of
the Queen Queen to h6
targeting the h2 pawn and maybe
considering the the potential Queen h4
check so after King g1 Bishop e6 dinar
is Roberts King ran to h1 and now white
is up upon and it's a question of
whether black has enough firepower to
continue the attack and we see now the
white bishop on e - that's a pink piece
that cannot go anywhere because the rook
and the Queen would suddenly have an
amazing cooperation and a checkmate on
h2 so now it's the white bishop who
maybe is not perfectly placed yeah white
white is a bit tied down here we can see
a couple more moves haven't played row
takes you to let's get to the current
position the the trade on c2 happened
and it's White's move
I mean if Y can just weather the storm
survived the attack white does have
extra pawn but I'm sure black won't be
looking to to trade off any major pieces
anytime soon white may try to exchange
the ropes with move let's say rooks you
want to get her last stroke out of the
board and then we say with the king but
dinara would probably play rook a to
attacking the pawn on a4 but mainly
keeping the rook on the seven on the
second-ranked
and keeping the attack but I see that
row Bishop f1 happened
at bishop f1 looks like a passive move
but it does defend the the g2 squares so
there's no immediate mate maybe white is
just trying to hold on we can also
imagine that bishop f1 would prepare
some some attempt to trade Queens like
Queen g3 given that White's queen is no
longer tied down to the bishop and I do
like this move from Robert because Queen
g3 very direct idea and now it's dinar
who has to come up with some way to to
proceed forward in the position I I do
have to agree that I realized the bishop
f1 and going back and trying to activate
the bishop which brings a question to
the move Queen g6 why to retreat the
Queen and not attack the h2 pawn can we
just go back to move 30 Syria saying
Queen g6 maybe not the wisest decision
from black does seem a bit peculiar
peculiar to leave the Queen on a
different square where h2 seemed seemed
to be the the clear targeted position so
let's say if I play Bishop f5 instead of
pin jisuk just to activate my Bishop I
also have a thread with Bishop d3 coming
it's very fast
how can why do we add here I'm actually
curious if there's some tactical line
like rook takes c2 rook takes you to and
Queen take a five going I mean it seems
like it's pawn grabbing but it's very
menacing threat of Queen Tate d5 Bonnie
2 is hanging so Brooke take E - I'm
realizing Queen take T 5 could be not
with Bishop to e6 so maybe not the best
flying for whites but maybe you also
have Queen d8 check here we do check
king of 7 I don't I mean if if white is
playing for anything that would be
perpetual but it seems like black can
probably easily escape given that
White's queen is only one doing any work
in the position
yes but I still I still don't really
understand them of queen g6 because I do
feel that white does not have much
counter play and when she said just
freed up the bishop on e2 right let's go
forward go forward to the current
position because a few more moves have
been played after Bishop f1 black played
Bishop d7 and dinara is low in time so
maybe when you when you are low on time
it can throw off your judgement and
maybe she didn't have the best judgment
between g6 trying to understand this
move Bishop to d7 doesn't appear that
the bishop is so much more effective on
that Square would have expected
something a bit more active like Bishop
f5 but maybe she just wants to keep a
constant eye on this pawn that's fixed
on a forward and we have a tournament
result for Group B their blood neumann
bellows he scored his first point well
congratulations to Vladimir defeating
Josh Reed L in what seemed to be a nice
nice victory winning the exchange
relatively early we can see my comer
there setting the clock josh freese L
not sure what he's doing but can't be
too pleased with two losses in a row so
we already have many results so let's
see the graphics for a group B or Group
A one of those yeah we have two games
pending in Group A all draw so far so
pretty peaceful game peaceful day in the
top group Alexander and itch drawing
Benjamin Bach Jeffrey Zhang drawing
Daniel Friedman and receive Tara Bailey
drawing Peter per hosta so nothing too
much changing in the sanding so far and
we also have prediction that Vera Cobian
may make a draw with yarrow Jerry book
and Renard has also a draw position
against some savvy and so let's see if
you're gonna have a decisive results in
Group B group a but let's move on to
group B a result right we have we
already have three results in Group B
Vladimir bellows and JJ Ally mirandy
defeating their their opponents today
and andrey zhuk open with a very quick
draw against camille dragon so a blood
of your day in group b two games still
pending
Robert August Arion against Norris
Sadhguru cassava which has been a very
exciting game so far and also Alejandra
Ramirez against Sergei might say go
let's take a look at that game the last
mention Alejandra Ramirez against
Vladimir Sergei match anchor
I don't remember looking at this game at
all I don't think we've looked at this
games yet today we maybe it's because
it's a drier positional battle but we
can see some some imbalances in the
position
Sergei montzingo is currently up a pawn
but it's a question of whether the
material advantage is enough to win
given this pawn on d5 not only isolated
but it's fixed on a light square and
it's it's defended by all of VAX pieces
attacked by whites Bishop and rook from
D 1 and G 2 so it appears that black
might have a hard time making progress
in this position this is a situation
when you are poor nap but you don't
really have any advantage for the pond
all you can do is to hold on to it but
on the other hand that's white you can
move your pieces around because you want
to keep attacking the pond you want to
make sure that you can capture it if
black decides to move somewhere else
that's right and Sergei Motte Cinco
thinking in this position what to do not
entirely clear I mean as black I would
love to play a recipe tacking move like
rope to c4 but this is simple simple
tactical blunder due to Queen takes c4
given there's a pin along the D file so
it seems like black has just tied down
here and Sergei doesn't have much time
to to play his next move given he's
already under a minute what to do maybe
just play a waiting move and get the
extra time do we predict this to result
in a draw I mean I think a draw is a lot
more likely than MBLAQ managing to win
this seems like Alejandro has has things
under control we also have to be careful
like if we are black and playing to play
something like Queen f6 to maybe try to
exchange the Queen's because the White
Queen can go to b8 know maybe capturing
but also to b8 and capture upon on a 7 B
6 and then the two points are free to go
so black has to be careful about the
background and the pawns tied on
squares right black does not want to
give back any extra material because I
mean if white leans back upon white
could very easily be better in the
position we can see a couple waiting
moves have been played going to the
current position black played King f8
and white played King f1 so not the most
interesting of moves not sure if if both
players are going for repetition or what
they're doing but we have another move
from Sergei Queen g7 perhaps signifying
that he's playing more for more than
just for a draw given that he hasn't
returned that came to g8 and so he needs
to make their three more moves to get 30
minutes the same for Alejandro battery
is the one who's keeping advantage so
maybe he just makes he just wants to
make some simple moves and get that time
that's true and Queen d7 appears to have
two ideas it does keep the a7 pawn
defended defending against any potential
Queen b8 ideas also maybe has a
positional idea of trading off the
not-so-great bishop on e6 for the much
better bishop on g2 so maybe black can
be pondering some future plan like
Bishop h3 try and simplify simplify the
situation and we should keep in mind if
black manages to trade off the bishops
the Queens and the rooks it's just a
winning King pawn ending for black so
it's easier said than done but maybe
something to play for so what if white
plays here Queenie Phi will be trying to
log the King on the f8 not being able to
go to e7 because the pawn would be
hanging on g7 and trying just to keep
keep the black pieces on the same
squares it's not a bad idea I mean I
would be I would be inclined to look at
Bishop h3 but I can't imagine it would
be working but maybe maybe it's an idea
that's an interesting idea so I probably
so what if I give checked so if you play
Queen B a check I would love to respond
with rook c8 just attack the Queen and
it seems like black is guaranteed to
trade off the bishops without too much
trouble
so it is it is Alejandro's move and he
is thinking in the position I would not
be surprised if I 100 plays a very
simple Kim Ji Won just putting the
question black back to black like what
are you doing in this position and Qing
Qing to Ji Won gets off this kind of
mini diagonal so it moved like Bishop
h3y could then very easily avoid the
betrayed the bishops do you don't think
I'm really worried here is if the King
gets to e7 and black is very happy of
playing King maybe Queen d6 and trying
to trade off the Queen's or having a
really good spot for the Queen oh you're
saying that black might go for some
exuberant plan of using the King to
facilitate the Queen trade we could we
could analyze that but the move has been
played by White's Queen to be a check
not expected that maybe just just
forcing black to commit in this position
now black has a choice between rook to
c8 and King e7 looks like we have a
result in the the Renacci um of I of Sam
Savion game which we weren't looking at
it so they agree to a draw yeah they did
agree to a draw it was somewhat
confusing position but perhaps neither
side had much to play for and Sam sofyan
he was in clear third place going into
this round so I'm sure he was maybe
looking for blood today but he still has
two more games to go to fight for the
top places and the renata my wife has
only his second draw here he has many
decisive results
he lost many times but he also won
against Peter Prohaska it's true so
which came to go to I see the the Cobian
Giroux boot game did not end in
repetition as we were expecting let's
take a glance of that game and see how
let's go back if you move see how var
actually escapes the repetition they
repeated twice so vara was gaining more
time on the clock and then var deviated
with the very illogical rook t3 hitting
the violin g5 and perhaps going for some
endgame after rook takes e4 Brooke 285
where white does have the extra
and maybe there will be some so many
chances for white in this position so
that's why you like did not want to go
to that and game and he wanted to keep
the Knights on board to make sure that
if I have a knight maybe I can trick the
right opponent I mean the kind of
general rule is if we have less material
we do not want to trade pieces so that's
what yarrow did and we have the current
position where black played rook c5
attacking the pawn on d5 that's right
and let's go forward to that moment rook
to d4 ninety six rook to e4 and then
rook c5 hitting the pawn on d5 and white
setup is a bit awkward here with the
rook on e4 Knight on c4
it is VARs move he's thinking in this
position hands are in that classic chess
player pose what to do is white would
you be brave enough to extend forward
with the move b6 I mean is there an
alternative to that I feel like I cannot
play rook e5 to kind of defend the pawn
because the knight on c4 c4 would be
hanging I'm not sure if there is
alternative I can play 96 okay that's
that's a possibility
yeah situations like this you always
want to consider your candidate moves
and in this situation
I mean pawn d6 is our option 96 is an
option maybe even 93 Knight to a3 is an
option so far has has something to think
about in this position which move would
would be your first instinct here I
don't like move Knight 83 because I feel
that after 93 I'm just hoping let's say
white plays Knight a3 I can play as
players black rook c3 and then again you
have to decide what to do with the night
and if you go to Knight c4 I have even
better space for the row better square
root B 3 and we should note this is a
very common principle in in end games
with rooks on the board you always want
your rook behind the past pawn in this
case black would be happy having the
rook constantly eyeing the pawn
on the B file unless there is like a
tricky part where I sacrifice the denied
and going and go for promotion so with
what if here I go b6 move like b6 these
lines can be fun to analyze and we
should note that these ideas sometimes
do exist but I have a feeling it would
be too slow in this position we move
like rook take a 3 because b7 runs into
rook b3 and rook before doesn't solve
anything because we're up to a8 so what
still has I mean what is porn AB but
it's not clear if we can hold on to the
pawn yeah going back to the current
position bar is still thinking trying
fect to trying to figure out which move
gives him the best winning chances I'm
realizing a move like 96 could just not
be playable due to rook rook d5 and then
hitting the night and still keeping an
eye on the pond
so maybe the moves to consider here are
b6 and 93 and sometimes positions like
this when you have many options you just
want to eliminate the ones that don't
work and focus on the ones which have no
clear refutation so we have dough smooth
candidates but players have a lot of
time if R has 22 minutes to think what
to do here so maybe let's give him that
time and let's look at the different
game let's go to tournament B we have
last two mortgages are being played
let's take a look at the Robert August
Orion against generous I do a cassava
because that game has changed a lot
since we last left rooks have come off
the board going back to where we last
left seems like seems like white just
was able to simplify black didn't win
this pawn on e4 and going to the current
position rooks got traded on c2 Queen c3
played and it's a question of whether
blacks pawns on the Queen side are
stronger or White's Center clump of very
beautiful pawns are stronger white does
have the initiative in the position and
seems like at any point Robert can can
bail out with perpetual check so it
seems pretty clear that he's a1 playing
for the
and and now it's his move probably
debating what to do with the Queen seems
like the simplest option would just be
to to go pawn grabbing but I am
realizing that's okay white has
something to do at this point in that
three currently being undefended and
also the pawns on the Queen side they
don't have any other opposing them so
they are really owned in Iran to a queen
that is true so maybe Robert Robert
could have some issues here we see that
he just played a move looks like Queen
d5 is on the board if I'm not mistaken
and it does allow Bishop take f3 with
check but maybe he's just planning the
simple Bishop to g2 making sure that
that efore is defended and this is a
really interesting imbalance I'm not
sure I'm sure we decide to prefer in
this position I think the good part for
Roberts for white is that the king the
black king is also exposed and I should
be able to have some perpetual check
Queen at five Queen c8 so I feel that
the white should be fine but I I mean
black spawns are really good on the
Queen side so I think white will be
forced to go for some type a check
that's possible these these types of
positions can last a long long time
especially with Queen still on the board
in a relatively open position I mean
both sides will have might have a hard
time making progress and yeah at some
points maybe in the later future Robert
could bail out with Perpetual but don't
feel like he's going to be trying his
best to play for a win in this game so
let's move on to a different game or
actually you know the 2018 Grantchester
is about to start
so we can talk about that that is true
we have two very exciting events coming
up this August we have the st. Louis
Blitzen Rapids second year in a row this
tournament is being held and I was here
last year it's such an exciting event so
many strong players last year Kasparov
came out of retirement to play it I
don't think he's playing again this year
but it should still be very exciting the
event takes place August 9th through the
16th and the viewers can find out a lot
more information
Grantchester org and following this
event is the sixth annual Sinquefield
cup all the 16 to August 29 very strong
grandmasters I was trying to find out
which Grand Master's confirm their
participation but what I heard it's not
yet clear who's gonna participate and we
can only speculate if Magnus Carlsen or
who's gonna play here that's true I was
told that the the lineups have been
determined for Paris and Levin so based
on those lineups maybe the hardcore
chess fans can determine which players
will be likely to play here in st. Louis
but we can expect great games and very
strong grandmasters it's always amazing
to be here and see so many great masters
everywhere around the city I hope I will
be able to if not be here to at least
watch it online
yeah and for everyone watching around
the country and around the world if you
can't make it to st. Louis just go to
grand chess to org and I'm sure they'll
have some star commentators back for for
some exciting chess so let's move on to
some of the remaining games still
battles in both groups under way maybe
we can take a look back at the game
between Alejandra Ramirez and Sergei
matsuhiko see if there have been any
developments but seems like not much has
changed since we last left I believe we
have the exact same position only with
with having moves king g1 and the bishop
is right back so the Queen is only five
I like that Queen there because it is
attacking the g7 pawn the King cannot go
to the center to help the Queen I don't
know how black and advanced here King F
1 is just happened King F 1 is played
and I mean it's a type of position as
white you can kind of just get your
ideal setup sit back and relax and
really just put the question to black I
would expect it should be a comfortable
draw for Alejandro but I would be
curious let's say you give this position
to a player I don't know maybe like
Magnus Carlsen could Magnus drum up
something here with the black side
having extra pawn maybe have something
to play for
that's a very good questions I mean
those the stronger to their masters are
more creative he or she can be so it is
possible to come up with something new
but we do have to keep in mind that this
position is very solid and white has
amazing pieces all attacking on all
being well placed so sometimes for me
there is just nothing else to do
sometimes it's just a draw I mean that's
true but from the black side there's
probably not too much to risk just
playing on in this position both sides
have received the extra half-hour but
sometimes if you can play on I don't
know like 1015 more moves maybe you can
get Alejandro thinking and if you can
get him lower on time put the pressure
on then there's more chances to perhaps
provoke some blunders later on in the
game so what we'll do is suggest here
for black that is a good question
putting the filling the question to me I
did like this Manute this potential
maneuver from earlier King g7 and and
Queens to d6 but we have to keep in mind
White's queen is pressuring the the pawn
on g7 so maybe to start with a move like
f6 here looks weakening but may be
playable you say f6 so you're forcing
the Queen to go away so I will probably
give you a check on b8 Queen B a check
and I'll go back to see it I just wanted
to get your queen out of the very pesky
v square if we look in this position
whites Queen is almost trapped you only
have one square if I'm not mistaken
let's go back to f4 that's true so I
will go back Queen it for maybe I can go
for some more activity here now
pondering this move rook c4 given that
the queen is defended on d7 but then I
go with check again you check again keen
e7
well sometimes as a as a black side you
don't want to be too too ambitious to go
for the wing because sometimes you are
taking some risk we can see the king on
e7 maybe white would have some some
counter punching options like rook e1 or
even Queen eight shades I feel of scream
queen AJ to go after g7 square
or actually pawn on g7 right and if if I
try and revert back with King f7 or
there could be the nasty Bishop h5 check
so maybe I can't be too ambitious here
from the backside but you do want to I
mean if you want to play for when you do
need to try to move the pawns because
the g7 is hanging I it's just very hard
to find something else what you do here
maybe we can try to to play a six or a
five at some moment because the Queen is
attacking the pond or a four afterwards
so there would be some trade but I can't
see how this can promise anything good
for black yeah a six another idea in the
position sometimes positions like this
you at least want to identify all of
your potential resources and then decide
what the best moment is to play whatever
these resources could be so resource for
resources for black include moves like
f6 or a six or Brooke c4 but sometimes
it's all about timing I see some players
on YouTube asking about the game Verito
beyond and yarrow jariabek nothing is
happening there
white did not move after rook c5 virus
thinking for 15 minutes there I don't
know if you want to go to that game Erik
we can take a look I don't think much
has changed bar still taking a ton of
time in this position seems like a
critical moment where I mean if R can't
find anything concretes I wouldn't be
surprised if if he just takes an early
draw here so nothing is happening here
var is thinking maybe it's gonna finish
in a DRA soon because we did look at
this position we saw that there are not
many spaces where to go with the knife
to keep the pawn and keep the advantage
but what did think for 15 min 40 minutes
now he's still thinking so maybe he can
come up with something creative
something interesting sometimes if you
go in the tank and you start thinking
for 15-20 minutes so you don't see
anything you won't be likely to see
anything if you think for another 5 or
10 minutes seems like that's what's
happening to var here maybe he's just
beginning to accept that this game is
going to end in
so that's the is that the only remaining
tournament a I believe so
well we should take a look at the
graphic and see which games are still
pending for this round and group a as
vara Cobian continues to ponder the
position only that game pending all the
other games are done if our does draw
the game will still be a half point
behind the CFTR bailey who has had an
amazing event so far and in sam Savion
in i mean still probably gonna be in
third place and sam is really gonna need
to put together some wins in the final
round so if he wants to make a run for
first place
let's glance at the pairings for around
a for group a we have benjamin bog PT
playing peter Prohaska
tomorrow yarrow cherrybrook against
massive Durer by lee Sam seven against
Morocco beyond Daniel Freedman against
rena jawad by alexandra in ditch again
Jeffrey Zhong what do you think Eric can
be the key match I mean the Sam Savion
game against Persian the Kobe and given
Sam is and will likely be in third place
after this round at bar and in second
place Sam will needs to go all out for a
win tomorrow if he wants to make any run
for first place but var is a tough
cookie
not an easy player to crack but Sam does
have the white pieces so maybe he'll
he'll try and show some creativity and
show some aggression in the opening and
play for a win another interesting game
tomorrow can be euro Jerry Boog against
vas adorable a sloop layer again Webster
player both very strong grandmasters
both playing great chess I look forward
to see tomorrow games that's right we
should look up the lifetime score
between those two players I'm sure
they've they've played many times before
not only in collegiate chess but both of
them played for the protest League on
rival teams
euros Arabic playing for the st. Louis
Archbishop's and received our Bailey
playing for our team the Webster
windmills so we'll have to go back in
the archive and the archive and see
their their lifetime score so let's look
at the pairing for Group B for tomorrow
round a round eight yeah we have
Daenerys adieu o Kesava against Andrea
Mott saenko
Camille dragon against Alejandro Ramirez
Tata
Abraham Ian against Andre sook open Josh
medow against JJ Ally Morandi
and Robert August Arion against Vladimir
Bellis any thoughts about this these
matchups tomorrow I mean we have come a
dragon against Alejandro Ramirez it's
gonna be a very important matchup for
camel who is the leader but I was
playing Alejandro who maybe can go and
try I mean he didn't have a best game
yesterday but today he seems to be okay
and maybe tomorrow is the time when you
know you want to attack you want to get
that point that's true I should also
note that even though Tata have had a
tough loss today we were talking before
the broadcast she might be in the
running for an I am norm she she isn't a
very strong field being the lowest seed
and if she can I know it's a long shot
but if he/she can win her last two games
there is a chance that she could get an
iron norm by the end of this tournament
so let's look at the standings for group
B who are the leaders right we have
camille dragon with what's still
maintaining the lead five points after
after seven rounds and two players close
behind JJ ally mirandy andrey zhuk open
a full point behind so they're going to
need to drum up some some exciting chess
tomorrow and we do have a couple games
still pending in Group B but that's not
going to affect the the leaderboard too
much and going into the final rounds
so let's cleanse back just quickly at
the verrico beyond again yarrow
cherrybrook and then I think that will
be that will be it for today yeah a few
developments in that game going back to
where we left off rook c5 played bar did
go for this this pawn advance pawn d6
given the rook defends the knight
defends upon so things are things are
defended for white in this position and
after rook b5 key to it's euros move but
var has exhausted a lot of time on the
clock and I'm curious if aro have any
any way to simplify this position maybe
the move Knight c5 any thoughts for the
backside I think at least white got the
King out and
to help but I wonder if I mean if I just
get my King also to King f8 King he ate
you can really play King d3 that's why
because of because of the fork so maybe
white made some advances but I'm not
sure if that's gonna be enough for for a
full point and I do want to switch gears
here for a moment a game which we
predicted was going to be a very long
fight has just ended pretty abruptly
with the draw seems like Robert Agassi
and went for the repetition against
Donora so do a cassava in what was maybe
a very direct line after a bishop to g2
we can see Donora abandon her king with
her Queen perhaps going for for some
counter play against the white king on
each one
we should note that Queen c1 is a maiden
one threat and Robert Robert just played
Queen D aids probably just offered a
draw
given that doesn't seem like quite has
any way of making progress given the
lack of safety for the white king on
each one I mean we did spread a that
Robert will go for some perpetual check
because black can attack the King and
black maybe can play and try for win so
this is a very very safe draw for white
that's right so we only have two games
going in both groups
the battle between Alejandro Ramirez
against Sergei MOT Cinco and of course
the ongoing battle between rusian
dacovian and euros Arabic I think we're
gonna wrap it up here and and let the
viewers watch their game watch the games
at their own leisure if you'd like to
follow all of the games you can go to us
chess champs calm the game start at 1:00
p.m. for for tomorrow the final day will
be two hours earlier at 11:00 a.m. and
of course our broadcast will be at 3:30
p.m. tomorrow so I hope you're gonna
join us tomorrow again see you tomorrow
yeah thanks for watching take care
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you